Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
Gitpod.
Before we do that, I just wanna take
a moment to say thank you to my
employer, Equinix Metal. They are a bare metal
cloud, and they provide the time and the
resources that allows me to invest in a
show and produce great cloud native learning materials
so we can all learn together.
If you wanna check out Equinix metal, please
visit
metal.equinix.com
and use the code Rawkode
dash live. This will give you $50
of credit. That $50 can get you roughly
one hundred hours of compute on our smallest
instance. So check it out, have some fun,
and let me know how you get on.
Now today to look at Gitpod,
I am joined by two
they're great team members, Christian and Sven. Hello.
How are you both?
Hi, David. Great. Hey. Good. Awesome. Thank you.
Would
you just like to just take a moment
to first introduce yourselves and then we'll talk
about what Gitpod is and how it can
help us?
Chris, do you wanna start?
Yeah. I can I can have a go?
So my name is Chris. I'm the chief
architect at Gitpod.
And my role is to
make sure we stay sort of technically coherent
and, you know, decide on how we build
this
or guide the discussion on how we build
this thing and make sure the team stays
aligned on that from the technical perspective.
Yeah. I'm Sven.
I'm one of the cofounders
and CEO of Gitpod. And,
yeah, my passion is like, I'm I'm an
engineer also, but I really, like, look into
the product
stuff and
yeah. It's in in entirety.
Awesome. So
should we start by just saying, you know,
what is Gitpod and what what problem does
it aim to solve?
Yeah. Of course.
So Gitpod is
dev environments in the cloud. Basically, our plan
is always be ready to code. So what
we wanna make sure is that developers
stop wasting their time on manually setting up
local machines,
you know, with databases,
compilers, stuff like that before they can start
coding.
We
it's pretty simple. Like, we apply lessons learned
from infrastructure's
code and continuous integration. So what you do
is you describe your development environment,
which is not only the IDE,
but all the tools you need. You describe
that in code
and have that part of your Git repository,
so it's versioned.
And with that,
when someone pushes a change, we can always,
you know, recreate
entire dev environments that are fully initialized and
ready to call. We do that in the
cloud. So when a developer comes by, wants
to start a dev environment on a certain
branch,
it takes a couple of seconds in order
to get dive into being creative and working
in code.
Yes. I think it's
this kind of tooling is is becoming more
and more important. You know, I think before
we went live, I talked about my my
aspirations of being able to survive on a
Chromebook
as my day to day machine. And one
of the challenges there is is having the
toolings to work on projects.
But even more importantly than that, you know,
I think making the path easier for open
source contributors to pick up a new project
and a language that they're maybe not all
that comfortable with with tooling that they're not
all that comfortable with and have a tool
that get pod where they can click button
and have a working environment for
for making their first contribution, I think, is
is definitely important.
So can we
if we understand what what's the process then
with Gitpod, you know, is this something that
we expect
the
maintainers of the projects to put together themselves
when they're making it available in open source?
I mean, yes. The the configuration for that
needs to be engineered by the team. So
the team decides on what what is the
perfect dev environment for all of us. You
know, there are means that you add your
personal
touches on on top with key bindings and
stuff like that. You can you can do
that for sure. But at the core,
we decide as a team, like, okay. Let's
we use, you know, this compiler and that
version, and we have this one time, and
we use that code generator, and we use
that database, or we have even 10 different
databases in our unit test we wanna test
against. And so that's all stuff you do
as a team. It doesn't matter whether you
do that in open source or in some
commercial project.
You of course, in open source, you have
even more external
collaborators,
contributors
for
whom you wanna make, you know, pay for
path, make it super easy to contribute, spin
up a dev environment.
But even in commercial projects, I mean, I've
I've been working as a consultant for
ten, fifteen years now.
I haven't seen a project,
like a commercial real world project where I
was up to speed in
in a couple of minutes. Usually, it takes
two days until we can do do some
work. Yeah.
Yeah. I remember an organization I worked at
a few years ago where they forced all
the developers to use an ID that was
baked inside of a vagrant image. And they
all had to use the same settings and
the same color scheme and the same key
bindings and all of that. And
I understand the intent there, but definitely not
the ideal solution. Whereas something like that seems
much more flexible. Now,
I think the most important question I'm gonna
ask you today is, does it have them
key bindings?
If
if there is a Versus code extension for
Vim, then yes.
Right. Nice. So that's okay. So it loads
Versus code extension. That's awesome. Let's
pull up my my screen. So this is
the Gitpod homepage.
If you're following along at home or wanna
check this out on the replay, is getpod.io.
So does
is Gitpod. Does it just use the Versus
Code extensions or is that built on top
of Versus Code itself?
Both. It's a bit yeah. Like,
the IDE part of that is really not,
like, the critical thing we wanna get across.
Like, what we really wanna achieve is that
developers
can bundle up the tools they love and
they wanna use they would use locally. They
bundle them up in this recipe
that Gitpod can execute and provide you in
a cloud. So you should be able to
use the IDE you love.
Right? When we started out, we saw, okay.
Like, Versus Code is a great IDE. We
we love it, and it seems to have
a market share that is significant and, you
know, and increasing.
So we looked at Versus Code and and
checked whether we can, you know, somehow move
it into the cloud, also talk
with them actually.
And so at that point in time, they
just came from the cloud. There was an
online version of Versus Code many years ago.
They moved it to the desktop,
built Versus Code,
and at at that point and they said,
no. We are not interested in changing the
architecture.
We wanna focus on desktop entirely. So what
we did is we
saw that there are cool components like the
Monaco editor and they, you know, develop the
language of protocols. So we took
those ingredients and created, an online ID called
Feya.
We moved that to the Eclipse Foundation because
that's really not the point. We wanna make
and get this good part is to build
yet another IDE.
We wanted to source this dev environment stuff
and give developers the IDE they love.
But fast forward two years,
Microsoft has changed its, you know, architectural decisions.
So they made Versus changed the architecture in
Versus Code so that it runs now nicely
in browsers as well. And, you know, probably
have heard of GitHub code spaces.
And so they did that in the open
source version. So since last week, you can
choose
and get part whether you wanna use Thea
or Versus Code as a browser front end.
In both IDEs, you can install any Versus
Code extension.
Alright. Nice. To
dwell on the point that really the IDE
that you're using is is something that you
can choose and not something that we prescribe,
There is a feature that's currently in private
beta even where it can bring your own
IDE as as a docker image, and that
could be anything, you know, Jupyter Labs, Jupyter
Notebook.
If you sign client, it could be just
a terminal with Emacs behind the scenes.
So, really, the the point is we want
to automate the the dev environment as a
whole, and the IDE is one part of
it. And we want to be orthogonal to
the IDEs
that you might want to use.
Alright.
So
yeah. That's
that's really important. I don't think I fully
understand that. I understood that as we were
coming into this. You know, I was thinking,
it's an ID that runs in the cloud
and provides us other stuff. But really, there's
just so much more to it than that.
So
alright. So from this homepage, I can see
a try now button just sitting there attempting
me to click it. So I'm just gonna
go ahead and do that. Let's see.
So
so I can just take any repository
and add it to the end of that
URL and it's gonna open it up for
me?
That's correct. So
I already opened a few in advance. For
the audience, what I have here is a
project called Git series.
So good. I wrote it twice. Once in
Rust, once in Go. I'll get answer that
another day of why I did that. But
it is a project that can scan, get
repositories, export metrics from it a time series
format.
I also have another project. I seem to
do a lot with Git now. Don't realize
this. But this one's called Git sync. It's
a GitOps operator written in Rust.
And I have an Equinix metal terraform provider
due to be renamed any day now. Currently,
it still says packet.
And I'm just gonna
add this to the start.
Does it a protocol matter? Should I remove
that?
It doesn't matter.
But for Gitpod, actually, I'm not sure if
it's back. No. Let's let's continue. I will
show you with the other repo.
Alright. So now it's just saying log in
and launch workspace.
So I'll authorize this.
Alright. So do you wanna give me a
little bit of
insight into what's actually happening here?
Yeah. So what's happening in the background
or what just happened
was that
Gitpod understood
from the URL that you provided or that
you that was the suffix, basically.
It understood which repository you wanted to open,
which
Git hosting provider you wanted it to open
from.
And
it, as you then saw, talked to to
GitLab, signed you in so that you got
access to to that repository.
And then behind the scenes, it started a
a Kubernetes pod
with the IDE in with user land and
with a default sort of image
that we call workspace full that has a
lot of tools
installed already
and started the IDE for you.
Alright.
I can see that it's downloaded all the
Go modules.
It's asking me if I wanna set up
the project or just never.
What do you think would be a good
first step here? Will we click never or
will we click setup? Should I just start
breaking We can set it up. Yeah. We
can set up your project.
It's it should be relatively
easy.
Okay. So the first thing you need to
do is,
like, you know, you you could use and
just code along here in in this IDE
now, but it's it's not
you know, it's there's no real kind of
automation
in there. So it's just, you know, it's
a checkout of of the context you've you've
started with, which is the default branch here.
With the Gitpod YAML, what you can do
is you can tell Gitpod
what kind of, for instance,
base docker image you wanna have
in your like, when you, you know, when
you in in your tools, you wanna maybe
install additional
tools like a database or stuff like that.
And also what kind of tasks should be
executed. So if you click create Gitpod YAML,
it analyzes your project a bit. And and
if you double click the Gitpod YAML tab
in the middle,
you can make it full screen. And you
see what it analyze. It's pretty simple. It
says, like, okay. When you ever someone starts
this project,
we have two things we wanna execute one
after the other. First, we wanna run GoGecko
build and go test.
And then afterwards, we wanna run,
actually, the one. So that's just the super
simple gold standard thing.
What is important here is there is this
two different life cycles. It's you know, there's
init and there's command. The point is that
init can be executed asynchronously.
So when you check-in this,
you can install a webhook on your GitLab
repository,
and then we'll Gitpod will run through this
interface
whenever someone pushes
a new branch and you commit to any
branches.
And it runs through that, and then it
takes a snapshot.
And then when a a real human being
comes along, wants to start coding, you don't
have to wait for this.
So this is, you very significant for a
long running build. Like, if you need to
download the the Internet because you have so
many dependencies or, you know, do stuff like
that, then you don't have to wait for
that. You get a fully kind of initialized
compiled
code generated
source code
within a couple of seconds.
Very cool. To to bring the point home
how much time that saves, if you do
that on on Gitpod IO or the Gitpod
IO repository itself,
you'll save about twelve minutes by not having
to sit there and watch PaintDry code download
and compile. Right?
Yeah. I could see
I could see a lot of benefits to
the push definitely.
And I guess in a really weird way,
if I were,
you know
assuming it wasn't 2020 and I'm out on
a, you know, holiday period, Christmas night out
with my workmates and I need to fix
something on my phone, I could I'm assuming
I could just pop that open and never
have to leave restaurant. So I like that
idea.
And not that I've ever had to fix
any production outage from a restaurant before. That
wasn't definitely wasn't painful.
Okay.
We actually had a a question just as
we were chatting there. So let's pop that
up. So
Ofer is asking, will we show how to
use or utilize Docker compose and have that
run containers when we start the workspace?
Yeah. We'll definitely try and get around to
that.
Okay. Now
should I update this docker configuration?
I'm assuming that it's just a docker file
that is used to provide the tooling environment
for this workspace.
Okay. That that's correct. So there there are
two ways you can provide the user land
for your workspace.
One is you can
list in an already built image, and we're
gonna pull that and use that.
Or you can provide your own Dockerfile,
check that in in your repository, and then
whenever you make a change to that and
open a new workspace on it, Gitpod will
build that for you.
Alright. I'm gonna click it.
Okay. So you provide some
defaults,
VNC.
Yeah. It you know, some not everything runs
in the browser yet.
So
if you need to do something that doesn't
run-in the browser, you need, I know, need
to run UI tests, for example,
then this image comes in handy. And it
starts a VNC server on a frame buffer
and then gives you web VNC view
to it.
Alright. Cool.
I'll just click custom.
And
I just it wants me to provide
an image with a name. So what is
the Gitpod workspace fill that it's suggesting here?
That's the default one. We have a like,
you know, that's the one we are running
currently on. Like, if you don't provide anything,
then we use the workspace full and it
it you know, the name is
accurate. It it has everything you probably might
wanna have.
So it's it's,
you know, it's
yeah. Batteries included
very big
image that is,
fast to pull because it's it sits on
every note already, pre pull.
But it's probably not what you really, you
know, in a professional context, you wanna, you
know, maybe say, okay. I really need this
version
of Go or I need that. No. And
then then you wanna be very specific, so
you would start with a hand rolled
docker image.
Okay.
I'll just skip this for now then. Okay.
Yeah. You can yeah.
You can now you could generate a Gitpod
Dockerfile,
but please just don't don't do that because
we don't need that for the simple project.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's that's kinda what I
was
getting there. So okay. So we can let
others know that this project, I'm gonna click
update with me because I just, click in
the blue button.
Alright. You can just close the tab on
the right. There's this icon.
Yeah. Click on the text. Alright. Let's pop
this channel down.
Let's see what that's done to my read
me then.
Alright. It wants me to update something and
just say, hey. This is It yeah. It
added this button, this batch to the top.
If you click the preview icon on the
top right,
yeah, that one
that one, you see what it did.
Oh, got it. Okay. So you've added a
badge then allows other people to pop us
open instead of Gitpod.
Right.
Excellent.
That was all
pretty painless.
So I guess and now I can start
making changes to this application and just develop
it as I normally would. Like, not really
much should change with my normal developer workflow.
Is that right?
Correct. Yeah. So if you open a
a Go file, for example, I saw earlier
the Go get
looks like it didn't go through because of
some native dependency.
But by and large, you know, it it
will run Go, please, behind the scenes.
It's the Versus Code Go extension
that we all know.
So it should we should feel right at
home.
Oh, yeah. It seems to have failed here
because lib get was
not available.
So
this is just a debian box. So in
theory, I should just be able to
install that. Right?
Let's see if I got sudo.
So this brings us to a
good point that is
currently in in feature preview. So we have
sort of this you could consider the better
feature channel
like you have with many other projects
that you can enable in the settings, and
this would give you sudo.
And then you could just do exactly what
you were trying to do.
If you want, we can go ahead and
and just enable that.
This would also, though, be a good use
case for the stocker file that we were
just about to create because this is something
that everyone in your team will need. Everyone
who opens this project will need that library.
So there's a good chance you'll want that
installed in the user land for everyone. Right?
You don't want everyone after they open the
workspace to have to go and do app
get install
Yeah. Lib get.
Alright. So what do you want me to
do first?
I think it it'd be best now probably
if we enable
the the feature preview just to show that
off, and it really helps sort of getting
that Docker file
ready.
To do that, if you on the upper
right corner on your avatar,
and then click on open workspaces.
And then again in the upper right corner
in the avatar,
hit settings.
And then there you see the feature preview
at the bottom.
Oh, yep. There we go. If you tick
that, that's it. And so the next workspace
any next workspace that you'll start will have
support for sudo, apt get, etcetera.
The the code that you just ticked is
exactly what
Sven alluded to earlier where we're really not
opinionated about the IDE that you want to
use.
And there is some some
code support in there. It's still a bit
rough around the edges, I would say. So
I wouldn't recommend that that we take it
on now. Okay. Just, you know, some things
like
extensions being preinstalled are are still in the
works. About to land the PR is actually
on the repository.
So let let's continue with that. Okay.
And so that just saves automatically. Right? There's
not anything I have to do here. Okay.
So I can just close this. Mhmm.
And then we come back to here. Do
I need to reload this workspace?
You would have to stop and start it
again.
And to do that,
again, the upper right corner or the command
palette in in Versus Code. So command shift
p
and then stop workspace,
and that will
it's important to note that this is only
something you have to do, you know, by
now because we're changing these settings.
Once these settings are enabled, this is not
something that
that you'll have to do again. Okay.
So we're just waiting for this to stop.
I'm assuming my start button's gonna come back,
and we just go straight back in. Correct.
Nice.
And it's backing up now, like, the file
system of your workspace,
you, you know, get that state back again.
But when I've earlier
explained that we have this prebuilt feature and
and, you know, it it allows you to
skip the waiting,
The real reason behind that, you can start
the workspace now.
Yeah. I just thought this was quite interesting
here. Uh-huh. It's kind of
all those changes that I started to make
are still gonna be available when I come
back, which is really cool.
Yes. It
also tells you what what did change, and
you see that here in the tab. So
if you have a bunch of Gitpod tabs
closed, you can see what state they were
in, and it will also show that in
in the dashboard.
So, you know, if you have a list
of in the workspace list so if you
have a list of workspaces,
you can then still see what was in
in case you left something accidentally, for example.
Okay.
What's
explicit we are so explicit about these changes
thing and so on because we know we
wanna
emphasize
or allow people to treat dev environments as
ephemeral or disposable. So we would always, you
know, start fresh.
You usually don't do that, like, stopping and
starting workspaces again unless you are working on
the long running feature branch. So
and so when you go to your workspaces
list, this is just reading your history. Like
and there should be little reason to restart
these workspaces because
you can always rely on the automation and
get the freshly prepared ones on the latest,
you know, state of your branches when you
go to GitLab and start from there. So
that's that's the workflow. You always start fresh
and even in parallel, and then you just
close your tab, and Gitpod will take care
of,
you know or even garbage collect. Like, we
are stopping the workspace.
And then eventually,
after fourteen days of inactivity, it will be
garbage collected
so you don't have to clean up after
you. Yeah. Cool. To to illustrate that point
further on a good day, I'll have anywhere
between 20 to 25 workspaces.
Right? I'll have I'll have two to three
running in parallel like this and that PR
that I'm trying to review, this feature that
I'm working on while I'm waiting for build
somewhere else.
And
the only time I really ever restart one
is when I come back from lunch, and
that's about it.
I think the
okay. So I've got two questions.
First one, ask me if I want to
install a Chrome extension. I am curious what
what does that bring to the environment?
It adds a button
like that says Gitpod
to all your
to every GitHub
and Bitbucket org and GitLab repository,
even pull request, merge request issues. So you
can start from any you know, you see
on the Internet, you see code. There is
a Gitpod button next to it. You click
it, and then you you can code on
that. Awesome. Good. That light led me onto
my what my next question was gonna be
there because because you just said, you know,
about pull requests. I mean, if I have
a pull request for the repository and, you
know, it's not always great to look at
it and that they get help views, and
I can open that specific
bar, that branch, that revision, and say that
we Gitpod and actually walk through the changes
in a more familiar environment. Right? K.
Yeah. It even noticed that you are starting
on a if you start from a full
request,
the IDE doesn't open like this. It opens
with the changes on the left, and then
you can skip both through that, and you
see, you know, these editors.
And you can even comment in line in
the editor.
Like, you know, you don't have to go
back to GitHub in order to do your
code review. You just do it from the
IDE. You can even approve or, you know,
comment, reject, whatnot.
Okay. I I mean, we're definitely gonna have
try that to fill in because
I'm into a help some Helm charts repositories.
I run the influx DB Helm charts, and
it gets a lot of pull requests. There's
a lot of work, and anything that can
simplify that for me, like, I'm immediately sold.
So hopefully, we can try that. Let's let's
do something rudimentary with this go set up
and then maybe we can look at one
of those pull requests and see how that
works.
Alright. So
we enable the feature preview because we want
the ability to do
sudo. So I'm just gonna do sudo l
s and that now worked.
But you also suggested that
this lib get two is not something that
we want to have everybody installed manually. So
we probably want to add our own get
pod dot docker file.
Is that correct? Mhmm. Yes. Okay.
What's the flow that that I found works
is, you know, first, you gotta find out
the exact name of the package that you
want to install. So now we could in
in this terminal, we could do
up get updates, up install
Just to make sure we're picking the right
package and that our up go get runs
through,
and then we we take that and we
package that into the into the Docker file.
Okay.
So
we will need lib get to dash dev.
Is there a helper for creating this Docker
file or should I just go ahead and
do, like, new file here?
There is. You can also open the view
on the right with the Gitpod
icon again and
update Docker configuration once more. Use default.
And, yes, generated Gitpod deck of the
k. So now okay. Yeah. So that name
is completely wherever I want it to be.
This is just what's set by default. Okay.
Cool.
Because I I I'm very fussy over fails
on my repository, so it states that that's
an option.
Alright. Let's get this working then. So
now I ran an app update
from this terminal because I'm just used to
container images, really stripping all that stuff out.
Is that the same for Gitpod or does
that step unnecessary
here?
I think you need to do that. Yep.
Be wary
beware that this later will run headless. Right?
So if you do apt install or apt
get install, you need to make sure that
it's not asking exactly. It's not asking for
confirmation or anything like that.
Yeah. I'll I'll just set this to
front
end.
This environment variable will later be available in
your workspace too. So if you set it
here like this, then in your workspace, it
will be set like that as well. Exactly.
Okay.
With a with a cleaner.
And this does not run as rules, so
it better put sudo
before.
K. Oh,
provided there.
There we go.
Sudo.
So
now that I've added the Dockerfile and made
some changes, is there anything I need to
do to
switch to this new image?
Yes.
You need to get that into your remote
Git repository.
So you need to create a branch
and push it there because it's Git first.
You know, Gitpod yeah. You you open new
dev environments from from Git.
So if you have it on a branch
or on your phone, whatever,
and you start different moments from there, Gitpod
understands. Okay. That's,
you know, that's the configuration
I need to to choose.
I'm assuming I can just use these tools
here
to Yep. To do that. Okay. So I
can say,
add it
both configuration.
You can also create a branch in the
status bar where it says master.
If you click on that, then it will
ask you if you want to create a
new branch.
K.
Then
You need to stage.
Yeah. This plus.
And then the small tick up top.
Yep.
That's it.
And to push, you can use the command
palette. You can use Gitpush in your terminal.
And
that's it.
Okay. So
I guess I should pull this back up
from here.
And it was good series go.
Right.
So should I just create a merge request?
Yeah. You don't have to in order to
change it. You can to test it, you
can also just go to the branch, load
it on the features.
You mean from
Yeah. You you select that one,
and then you see the web ID button.
I wanna show you, like, use the drop
down and choose Gitpod because Gitpod has a
native integration, GitLab, so you don't need to
prefix this stuff.
Okay. Now we can use it. We have
just had it enabled once.
And this is opening
the branch.
Okay. Correct. Do see the the context URL
on top?
Yes.
Right.
Oh, I broke it.
So I'll start with the default image and
fix that, I guess.
You can go to the to the other
workspace
and fix the problem and then just force
push again.
But I I couldn't stop the problem.
Oh, yeah. I forgot I think it was
signed. So I I just tried to run
it as I as I command. Mhmm. So
okay. So I'll just amend that commit so
we can stage this.
Use you can use the amend button.
And then Right.
Just that one. Perfect.
Okay.
And you guys still gotta push. So if
you again, you can just use the command
palette for that.
First push. Oh, yeah. Yeah. The fourth push.
Yeah.
K. So
let's just
pop back to here
and try that again.
It's attempting to and build our custom image,
which should hopefully this time work.
Yeah. It looks better. Okay.
And you were saying
this only does this once.
So anyone else that now comes to this
project, they're just gonna get the built version
of this image and not have to wait.
Right? Correct.
Until you make a change to to the
image of or to the file, of course.
Okay.
And what we should see the reason that
we did this was because let get caused
our goal build to fail earlier. So now
when this pops open, we should see our
terminal set in there whether
a built binary, I'm assuming.
Okay.
Correct.
Yeah. And it should execute the things we
listed in the tasks in the Gitpodium now
because we pushed the Gitpodium as well. Excellent.
Oh, no.
I think this is just a good thing
now. This is not anything that we've done.
Yeah. I'm not sure about that error message.
Maybe there's some version. The version in the
Ubuntu
package doesn't
match up with what we're expecting here.
Yeah. You're correct.
We installed web 28 because that was available
in Ubuntu, and this uses version
30.
So let's just see if it's fixed. If
not, we can move to another project.
I'm gonna have to get a specific version
for that, I think.
Let's see.
Leases
twenty eight eight six
twenty eight.
And then
download.
See if that makes it a little bit
happier.
And go build.
I'm gonna need some.
I broke it.
Oh, well. Not important.
Oh, it's just added that back in, actually.
This is why I tried to avoid using
Libgit whenever possible.
There is a
good good
go native
Git implementation as well. Oh, really?
Okay.
I don't know if I really wanna keep
trying to fix this. Yeah.
So the the the v 30 import seems
to be across a few files.
And I just don't think that's important. So
let's pop open something else then.
Let's do the Rust project.
Feeling brave. Right?
Think
let's see. Gitpod I o slash
and
slash whatever we wanna call that. Get menu
environment.
So you mentioned earlier that Gitpod tries to
kind of does it do language detection? It
tries to work at what sensible default makes
sense for each repositories.
Is that correct?
Maybe.
Yes and no. So it it does that
in in some very simple cases like the
ones that we've seen for for Go,
but
it's not very
yeah.
Okay. Elaborate.
Oh, because this is using the workspace
fill image,
is that just mean as prebaked with
binaries and languages, like support for popular languages?
Mhmm. Because I do have access to Rust
c here.
Yep. I do have PHP,
L. I mean, I'm having quite a lot
of languages here. So Node, Python,
Go.
Oh, alright.
So let's click setup project again.
We'll create the Gitpod.
It has detected oh, yeah. It's a bit
small.
What's that? So that detect that was rust.
It knows that I wanted to a cargo
build, a cargo watch.
I don't
think we're gonna need that.
I'll update the read me with the cool
button again.
Not sure what happened there.
K. Let's skip it. Is there a read
me?
I'm
a bit of a cowboy developer, so it's
very likely that there's not for sure.
Alright. And then we'll just push that and
start. Okay.
So I can do a cargo.
And the crates is gonna compel that one.
Maybe gonna work. You know, I don't even
know. I've picked another repository that uses libkat
again. So who knows what's gonna happen?
Maybe it's happier.
So can we come in? Sorry, Nico. Sorry.
One thing that, you know, might seem minor
but actually really works in
in the daily life of a developer is
that exactly because your workspace is now running
in the cloud,
download speeds are just so much faster.
Like, in downloading libraries,
dependencies,
docker images, you name it, you know, it
just flies off. It's
Yeah. Definitely.
The download speeds were pretty quick. Although, unfortunately,
I don't think you can speed up the
Rust Belt times, which are notoriously bad. So
We can eliminate them by, you know, running
them in a prebuilt. Like, all everything we
are waiting here for would be something we
could do as a cleansing.
Well, that was pretty quick, and I've I've
actually I think this is they're just working.
Target.
Oh, no. This is just a library, so
there's no target. So, again, that worked.
Now this is
I I would just call it as normal
now. Right? Like, I would pop open my
file.
Oh, that's my commented stuff. There we go.
And I have everything that I need to
work. Awesome.
And are there any features from
this ID interface that you wanna cover before
we we carry on? Is there anything here
that is maybe slightly different to the way
that I would work normally?
The thing is jumping out to me. I'll
just throw it there as a suggestion. I
I see no open ports.
Mhmm.
Yeah.
So
what we're doing there is if you have
some service running in your workspace that listens
on a port, Gitpod
will detect that and then will make it
available
outside of the workspace. You can open that
in in your browser.
And by default,
they are private,
meaning that only you can access it because,
you know, you're logged in to Gitpod.
But you can also make them public, and
then anyone can just access that.
So you could, I don't know, provide an
endpoint to some other service, or you can
share that with a colleague to download something,
stuff like that.
Okay. So does that mean
random stupid
oh, I don't oh, yeah. That'll work. If
I just install NGINX on this,
I can just close that and someone can
just browse to engine x?
That's correct. Oh, it detected it as well.
Alright. Open a preview.
I have an engine x page.
Make public.
That's pretty cool.
Nice.
So obviously, if I was
that's again me, I'm on farm today. I've
picked two really bad examples for showing off
a feature. But if I was working on
a a website or a React application,
been able to just run that dev server,
expose support like I have done for NGINX
here, and give that link to people. They
can just come in and see exactly where
I am, what's working, what's not working, etcetera.
Is there
like, if I want if you wanted to,
like, pair with me on an issue, is
there, like, any support for that
where we'd be able to modify the code
at the same time?
So there is some there are two ways
of of sharing your workspace.
One is you can share the the workspace
as it's running.
So
at the moment, this just means you're giving
someone else access to, basically, to your machine,
right, like your workspace. But the
example is like you're handing your laptop to
someone else, kinda like that.
The you share some of the the terminals
at that point,
and we're still working on adding some, like,
Google Doc style life editing that you also
share editors.
And the other mode of sharing is where
you can share a snapshot. So say you
have a problem right now or you have
something that you would like to demonstrate,
then you can create a snapshot of your
current state,
which produces a link that, then you can
put into an issue, share on Slack, something
like that. And then someone else can go
and open that link and get a snapshot
based on your current state, but it's gonna
get a workspace, excuse me, based on your
current state, but it's gonna be a separate
workspace. Right? It's like a copy
that was branched off it and where you
took the snapshot.
Okay. Cool. So you are working on Google
Docsys style code editing
stuff. Nice. We do. Yeah. In theory, you
could also use the live share
extension from Microsoft.
It's just that their license doesn't allow it
to install it in Azure
in in non visual studio products at the
moment.
So but we are working on a, you
know, on
on some collaborative editing extensions for the.
Very, very cool. Okay.
You shared a command with me. Yeah. This
is a really quick way to get a
get a web server up and running. So,
you know, short of installing NGINX, if you
just need a web server that serves a
file,
you you push that in, and it's
gonna spin up a web server for you.
Alright. Okay. Nice thing is that that works
independently of any kind of, you know, whatever
whatever you have installed. Behind the scenes, it
just downloads a gold binary and runs it.
So this is gonna work. And I could
never remember the Python line or, you know,
the PHP line, and it's just gonna start
with stuff. It's really handy for debugging.
Yeah. That's a really cool tip, actually. I
wasn't familiar with that. So
alright. Let's we got another question from over.
Working on my computer, I can save a
file today and it will be available forever.
And Gitpod, how long can I keep files
that I saved in ID but have not
yet been pushed to the repository?
There
yeah. I mentioned before we have an automatic
garbage collection thing. So by default,
if you don't restart your workspace for two
weeks, then it it
gets
deleted.
There is one another week
where we we could restore the state.
But you can pin your workspace. If you
wanna have a long living workspace,
so you wanna do the same everyone does
locally, like you have this, you know, stateful
stuff that you massage over
your lifespan, then you can do that in
Gitpod as well. You can have one workspace
pin it, and then it will never be
coverage collected. You can restart that, menu the
sync, and so on. It's just, you know,
we are trying
to
educate people to
get rid of that because
it is, you know, the the root cause
for configuration drift
and
and very
different states in in environments
where,
you know,
you you cannot really call this dev environments
as code if you do not really execute
the automation all the time. If you do
it once and then you massage it from
there,
it you know, it's it's it's nice
for starters,
basically, but but then you you do the
same stuff you do locally.
Yeah. You're just trying to encourage some best
practices for people across the board. Right.
So if I just close this tab,
that workspace is gonna continue to run
until I go back to it, until it
gets garbage collected.
But, you know, is there a way that
is should I, like, click stop?
Like, our
So the workspace is gonna run for another
two minutes after you close the tab just
in case you accidentally closed it and, you
know, command shift t, still there.
So it does that.
You can also explicitly stop it
in the file menu in the command palette
Okay. Whichever suits your your workflow.
Alright. Yeah. And if if forget about it,
you know, you get distracted, you go to
lunch or whatever.
The time out is
thirty minutes
by default,
and there are there are ways also to
extend it to three hours in in some
of the professional plans. But yeah. I think
thirty minutes is is is
pretty pretty okay. Then in that case, you
just come back and you see, oh, it
stopped. You started again. You touch a new
new look.
Alright. Thank you.
I'm just gonna play with this now,
see if I can find some extensions.
I changed this theme. It doesn't seem to
be returning.
Yeah. So we are like, the IDEs and
Gitpod, they do not point to the Microsoft
marketplace.
But, again, that is
not okay due to the terms.
So in order to
make the all these open source, these code
extensions are available to everyone and also competition
projects like like Gitpod and so on. We
created the open BSX marketplace.
We moved that to the Eclipse Foundation so
that it's really on a vendor neutral place,
you know, that. And then now this this
is kind of getting adoption. So Versus Codium,
like, that is the real open source version
of Versus Code. They are also pointing to
OpenVSX
now by default.
Gitpod, like, all CIR IDEs
would point to open the as expected fold.
Yeah. And if there's something missing, you can
go to the project
and, you know, create an issue
and and just, you know, make sure it
it gets added.
Okay. I'm just gonna keep clicking stuff.
Oh, there we go.
That's actually the one I use locally sometimes
anyway. Very cool.
Alright. Let's close this down.
I really wanna check out the pull request
stuff that we talked about earlier.
So let's pull that up.
And well, I need the extension then to
do this or
assuming No. Hub won't have the same native
thing like GitLab had.
No. You just use your port request.
Okay.
Alright. Let's just pick this one.
So can see.
Code spacing. So did I just get pod
at the start?
Correct. Yeah. Correct.
If you have the the browser extension installed,
then you're also gonna see a a button
in the upper right corner.
Alright. Cool.
And this is gonna give me a slightly
different view that we've we've seen with the
last two projects because it's detecting that I
was at a pull request from this.
Correct.
Okay. What have I got?
Oh, so it's just straight into the the
death mode.
I can click through the files.
Double click. Double
click and then And
then you can also use the cursor
keys in order to navigate through all the
changes one by one.
And you can add columns if in case
you have questions or
k. So,
I mean, I've already approved
this, but if I wanted to add a
comment,
what's Mhmm.
I would say that You hover over
the the change line on the right hand
side, like
and you see this
conversation symbol. You click on it.
Ah,
okay.
So this is pretty it feels pretty similar
to what I would actually do from the
GAP site. I can have the single comment
or actually start a review and and build
up all those comments. And Right. And you
would also see all existing comments here. There
is a comments view even.
And also on the right hand side, you
see the GitHub symbol.
There you see more details on the full
request.
And so you see conversations. If you click
on conversations, you would see, you know, existing
conversations.
To the files and see them in the
in the different contexts.
Very, very cool. This is a much better
experience for working with a pull request than
working from the GitHub UI. I like it.
It also
means you can try it out directly because
you have a full blown dev environment. You
know, this isn't just yet another view on
on the PR itself,
but you have a terminal. And if your
project is Gitpodified,
if you have a configuration,
everything is, you know, set up and ready
to go, you can run tests,
debug even,
and then try it out proper.
The workspace fill doesn't come with helm, I
don't think,
with control.
But I could provide them with my own
image because this is a help charge repository.
So the tooling that I need is
kinda specific.
Alright. Is there any integration with GitHub actions?
Like, would I be able to see if
the
if the last run was successful or if
it failed or what failed? Or is that
something I would have to jump back over
to GitHub to investigate?
Yeah. There's nothing special about that, probably, an
extension around that that you could install.
But, yeah, we do not use GitHub actions,
so
I don't really know.
Okay.
I mean, I guess that's the other cool
thing is that this has access to the
open BSX
marketplace. So if there's an extension out there
that already has GitHub action status support, then
it's just gonna magically work anyway. So that's
pretty cool. Thanks.
Do I have the ability to approve the
pull request from here?
Yes.
Usually, revenue changes.
Yeah. There we go. And then And then
I can just review this. I can just
approve it again.
Oh, I think permissions.
We need a new
scope.
Interesting.
Yeah. I don't think I
can't remember if I authenticated with GitHub or
not.
Maybe I did.
You can review that in the upper right
corner on your avatar.
There is a point called access control.
The second that one.
They can see what permissions
your current token has on.
Okay. Yeah. I
write public repos is, I guess, the thing
you would need.
That's annoying.
Let me grab that.
Yeah. So by default, we try and, you
know, grab the least privileges
for your account possible. And then, yeah, as
you need more,
usually, we'll ask for it.
Alright. That worked. I've now approved it again.
And I can be And you can jump
yeah. You you
can even merge or go back to GitHub
by clicking on the the issue number on
top right.
In fact, I can merge it from here
where it's asking me if I wanna do
a squash or a rebase, or I can
click the issue number, come over here, and
just go ahead and do that. So there.
Nice.
That's very convenient. I can see
just how useful that kind of is there.
With regards to the
the setups,
how would one contribute
to Gitpod to understand that this was a
Helm chart repo? Like, what would be the
process for that? Like, if I was, hey.
I work at Helm charts a lot. I
wanna make Gitpod work better by default for
these kind of repositories. Is there as there
some way for me to contribute that towards
a project?
The the way you would solve that is
for your project. You know, we can't we
we like, Gitpod is really designed to be
non opinionated about what kind of projects
to support. So we want you we wanna
allow developers to just say, okay. I I
need this tool, that tool, that CLI tool,
that extensions, and so on, and please bundle
that up for me. So you would put
that into your Docker
the Docker file as we did previously with
with Git library.
We would add few control and helm
as part of your Docker file. If you
say, this is a really common case, and
I know there is this, you know,
detection mechanism and get what I wanna contribute
to that. Of course, the Gitpod is open
source. So if you go to GitHub, Gitpod
IO Gitpod,
which is a repository,
and you can, you know, look whether there's
an feature request around this already or you
file one and then set indicate
you wanna contribute to us, and we we
can see whether that fits the scope of
the project
and and where to best to make to
the contribution.
Yeah. I guess what I was
more I guess what I was curious about
was, like, you know, if I come here,
for instance, and I add the Gitpod.YAML
Mhmm.
You know, when we added that custom Dockerfile,
really all we did I can't remember the
exact syntax, so, you know but roughly, we
said, hey. There's this image
which is built from this file. Can I
just tell it to use
say, published some
Gitpod images called Helm
and tell people, hey? If you if you
want to add a Gitpod YAML to your
project, then use this image and it'll come
with all the tools that you need for
Helm, you know, rather than all these other
developers also adding their own Gitpod Dockerfile,
you know, providing maybe some semantics around that,
I guess.
So Yeah.
Of course, you can do that. Like and
and also and we have this, you know,
docker images
repository
where we maintain those that were proposed when
you, you know, earlier used to set up
with it. There were a list of files
or docker images that were proposed. Right? Workspace
full, but also the one with VNC or
different databases and so on. Those are maintained
in an open source repository,
and there are some some more, you know,
there are for very typical setups,
then
it might make sense. Yeah.
Okay. Perfect.
So
let me ask another question then.
Do you use Gitpod to build Gitpod?
Sure. We
and we have done so for for quite
a long time at this point.
Two years easy.
Okay. Does your Gitpod have a Docker compose
file or should I throw one together in
this project? No. Okay. Let's throw one together
in here. Okay. And then alright. So we'll
do that just so we had a question
about how that would work. So I show
that and then we can open get pod
and get pod and then I think that's
a pretty good overview of of what get
pod is and how it makes developers lives
better. So
let's see.
Sure. I can remember how to build one
of these things. So
let's just do
engine x. Assume we're gonna run that,
and I can just add the ports.
And
I'll add one more.
I see I can remember how to do
it, then I would get it wrong. Okay.
Let's add something with PHP.
Put it in CLI image.
So this is a really
simple and contrived over a compose file. I
mean, that's just a little bit bigger.
Let's close this down just now.
We do have access to Docker Compose and
the workspace fill
image.
Correct.
So the first thing you would wanna do
is actually start the the Docker daemon.
And this is still a preview feature, so,
you know, we're still flushing out the UX,
and it was important to give people access
to this as soon as possible.
For now, to start the Docker daemon, you
type sudo
docker minus up,
and that will do the rest.
And that just started the
the docker daemon now.
Okay. How do I open a new channel?
There we go.
And would I just work with my standard
tooling normally? So I would just run a
docker compose up here. Yep.
Yeah. We don't it doesn't matter if that
container exits. It's not really important.
It's pretty quick at downloading the images, benefits
of cloud.
And my connection's not that fast, so that's
pretty cool.
You said that the the start of the
episode, this is just running as a Kubernetes
pod?
That is correct. Yes.
So the
Gitpod as a whole
so now it did the Docker compose up
and recognized that there's something running.
And and the status bar where it says
port, if you click that again, then you'll
find a button where you can
exactly open browser.
There you go.
So, I mean, that's just
that's just my native dev workflow. Like, you
know, that could be you know, I've added
PHP,
but this could be MySQL.
It could be any it could be Postgres,
MongoDB.
My application would just be configured to speak
on local host like in any other
other setup. There's nothing particularly
it it doesn't change anything, which I like.
Like, all my native tooling is still the
exact same, only I'm using someone else's computer,
which which is a nice benefit. Which you
don't have to set up. Which you don't
have to set up. Exactly. Yeah.
Alright.
It was just too easy.
I'm very impressed. I I I like it.
It's just,
you know, I don't feel like I've been
there's not been any friction. There's not been
frustrating. I've just clicked I mean and the
fact that I can just use Gitpod.io as
a prefix on any repository and pull request
is is very very cool. You've definitely put
a lot of effort into the kind of
user experience here and I think that changed
too. So great job.
Alright.
Let's do our if there's any more questions
or anything that you wanna understand about Gitpod,
feel free to drop them in the comments.
We'll open up the Gitpod repository now.
And I'm assuming it's just gonna work as
well, but still be fun to do. So
do you host the Gitpod source code on
GitHub, GitLab, or somewhere else or both?
It is GitHub.
GitHub.
Currently.
Alright. Let's pop over.
Gitpod.io.
Yeah. Right.
And we'll add a prefix.
So would you say this is the best
example of a project configured for Gitpod usage?
For ourselves,
probably. But for people who are not so
involved in it, I guess,
it's good. Like, examples are pretty good if
they, you know, get out of the way
and show off, you know, the thing you
really wanna show. So I like, for instance,
stuff like these,
the
pet clinic project or to do this typical
to do apps that have this,
you know, conflict. Everyone knows the problem and
everyone knows what's going on there, but then
you have still, like, this configuration with the
database and app servers. And the really good
real world
configuration is also the GitLab
project itself.
Like, you know, GitLab or GitLab
is using Gitpod for development.
And so that configuration
is also like, that's a that's a huge
project, and there is
you know, the configuration is is not
very simple. It's pretty involved.
Alright. So I'm sorry, Nico. Sorry.
Good thing to show here now is the
in the terminal in in both terminals,
So we had tasks running in parallel originally.
You see this this message,
this task ran as part of a workspace
prebuild.
And what that basically means is that, you
know, all the code in this workspace has
already been built. Dependencies have been downloaded.
You're ready to go.
So I'm always quite happy when I see
that banana because it basically tells me I
don't have to go and get a coffee
now.
Yeah. It's like that x k c d
comic where it's like, it's compiling. No. Sorry.
We've done that in advance. Stop slacking off.
So
two things that jumped out at me with
this repository. One,
the theme I installed in the last repository
is is now seems to be global for
my
my set my other experience. So I'm assuming
all my keyboard shortcuts and stuff like that
are all just gonna transfer between, which is
really cool.
I also noticed that this opened two terminals
say by say, is this something you've configured
in the Gitpod YAML or is this yeah.
Okay.
Let's take a look at it then.
Is this a mono repo?
Yes.
Good. I was gonna ask you a question
about mono repos.
That's very
handy. Alright. Let's drop this down
and see what we've got in here. So
but a prebaked dev environment image hosted on
GCR.
I go to the workspace location and a
checkout location.
And there are a lot of ports.
The tasks
we've not seen the before syntax yet. Is
that just like good runs before the edit
command itself?
Yeah. So the what the before does is
it runs before anything else,
and it does so independently of the
of the life cycle that Sven mentioned earlier.
So before will run-in
a prebuilt, but it will also run-in
not a prebuilt, like, if you start a
regular workspace.
Alright. And if you have multiple tasks, you
can just add this open mode to tell
to run-in a separate thing.
And there's a list of Versus code extensions,
which you think will make my life easier
here. So that's pretty cool too.
I don't know if this is
I I don't know if the conversations are
or whatnot, but, you know, Versus Code has
some sort of
fail like this. Is there any chance of
standardization there that I'd find this once and
it works on both,
know, Gitpod, the Versus Code, and and intelligent
products or whatever like that. Like,
do you see that being something that happens?
I I
guess so. Eventually, we see, like, you know,
how
what is commonly being used. But
given
that, you know, GitHub and and Microsoft have
a lot of reach and the dev container
format, and that's the format you are talking
about,
is pretty nicely designed.
So we have an our road map. Yeah.
The the plan to eventually support that. It's
not, you know, highest on the list, but
because also adoption is not really very
interesting currently.
But I I assume this will change a
bit. So maybe q two, q '3 next
year, we'll have some sort of support for
this format as well.
It's important that, you know, here we have
some
some more, like,
some additional information that we would need in
order to do stuff like the preloads and
so on because that's not supported by by
the format from
from this code.
But it would be a great start, and
it would make it super easy for people
to start the Gitpod workspace for repositories
that have the dev container
format for sure.
Awesome.
As I mentioned to add, like, I wanted
to add one thing to the thing you
mentioned before, David, regarding, like, your theme is
now on every workspace.
This is because you install that
as a user. I'm not sure if you
remember.
It was asked whether you wanna install it
on a workspace or a producer,
and installing things for user makes a lot
of sense. These extensions here
sorry. These extensions here are installed for workspaces.
That's why it's shared within,
you know, the Gitpod demo and then with
the with the with the entire team.
Yeah. I thought I remember the the pop
up. It said, do you want to make
us a workspace
extension or user extension? I had to select
user because I was don't wanna force my
theme on everyone else, I guess, that uses
this for j.
And is there anything we should show from
the Gitpod setup? Like, how does the mono
repository stuff work here? Like, you know, I've
got maybe a part of it. Let's go.
I'm assuming the UI is is TypeScript and
React. Like, how does this all work together?
Yeah. So the
the key challenge that we see is for
one that Go Please needs
each
Go
Go module to be its own workspace route.
So the way we set up the repository
is
on the components, we basically have the the,
you know, the components that make up this
project.
And they're a mix of TypeScript and Go,
And then
each Go component is its own Go module.
We don't have a root Go module,
and they're added as as workspace roots.
And that yeah. That's pretty much all there
is to it.
Alright. Awesome.
Is there anything that I should show here?
Or
is there anything
anything that we haven't covered so far about
the Gitpod configuration that you think is
is important to cover?
I mean, we could briefly show debugging.
I mean, know, at the end of the
day, it works like you would expect it
to work
in in your local Versus code as well.
But for exam you know, debugging go tests,
for example,
works just the same way.
Yeah. Actually, I think I've I've got that
vibe as we've been going through a a
few of the projects here. It's like, you're
not trying to change the way that people
work. Everything just all that experience that developers
have, they're they're continuing to use that even
though their environment has removed or moved to
to some sort of cloud compute. So and
that makes a lot of sense. Like, we
we you're probably not trying to rebuild people's
habits since they've got five years, ten years
of experience of working with their tools. Awesome.
Alright.
I'll just unshare my screen. Maybe we could
start to wrap up and talk about the
the roadmap for Gitpod, what's coming next. I'm
also really curious about
the
the pricing. Like, I've not paid anything. I've
not given you any card details. All of
this is just
free.
How does that work?
How does it work?
Yeah. It is we like, Gitpod is available
as a Gitpod IO, which is SaaS service.
And and then also there is this Gitpod
is open source, so you can also self
host it on your own Kubernetes clusters. And
for the self hosted version, there is the
possibility to, you know,
unlock certain features with an enterprise license.
We try to keep everything that is very,
you know, developer specific in open source and
everything that is more, you know, important for
larger teams or even companies, managers, and so
on. We would put into the
the enterprise license.
Forget about IO. We have a freemium subscription.
We want to support the open source development.
Also, we see this as,
you know, kind of a bit different way
of developing,
like, special especially with automating
and having these ephemeral dev environments and so
on.
So it is really a good opportunity to,
you know, lower the friction for open source
contributors.
So this is kind of a really important
thing to
have a good freemium subscription so that it
can be used in these scenarios easily and
people see and understand the value.
And, yeah, eventually, we might need to make
some money also, of course. But
currently,
you know, the focus is really on solving
this problem for the developer community.
Yeah. Definitely.
Can I use Gitpod on the free plan
with private repositories, or is that where the
the kind of the paying comes in?
You can use it for one month in
a trial,
but then after that, the paying comes in.
Yeah.
Okay. Awesome. And and what about the the
road map then? What what are what are
the team working on?
Besides those features we that are just currently
released in preview, like having Versus code as
well as the and also the
the pseudo and root support.
We need to flash that out
some more. We have a feature that Chris
built actually a couple of months ago already,
which is not entirely rolled out called full
workspace backup. That means, currently, we have a
certain volume, which is a workspace folder.
That is the stuff that we would back
up between the the Gitpod sessions.
With the new version, everything gets back up.
It doesn't matter where you have installed that.
We have some other, like, very exciting features,
the SSH access, which will allow to use
code remote SSH and also what Jetpod is
working on to connect with the pod workspaces
so you can even use your desktop IDE
in in together with the pod.
The collaborative editing
feature mentioned
before
is important.
I'm not sure, Chris.
I guess I
provided about a few things in the road
map.
I think for the
upcoming time, that's that's it. So,
we're also the the self hosted version that
mentioned,
we have convenient installers for those, you know,
that make it easy to to install them
on on GKE and AWS.
And we're looking into, you know, improving those,
making those more stable,
baking in more and more Terraform support on
that end.
So also from that side,
we're working on that.
Awesome.
Well, thank you very much for joining me
today. It's a really cool project. I'm I'm
hoping that it's gonna allow me to finally
migrate to use my Chromebook. I can see
even even beyond that on my Mac and
on my Linux machines why I'd still prefer
this kind of environment as well. There's a
lot of benefits
and consistency that can be adopted here. And
the pull request format was just basic on
the cake. I'm really happy with that as
well. Is there anything you would like to
say or share with us before we finish
up today?
Nope.
Yep. Thanks, David. That's what I wanna say.
Like, it's really nice to have this it
was also nice note having no preparation for
this session, but I also think it's it's
really good to have this spontaneous,
know, just talk about the product. Yeah. That's
good. Yeah. Some people love it. Some people
hate it. I'm glad you enjoyed it. I
I think we we had a really good
look at Gitpod here. I think it's a
really cool technology. I love that it's open
source as well. So, you know, great job.
Thanks again. I look forward to seeing what
happens in the future. And thanks again for
joining me. It was a pleasure. Thanks for
having us. Have a great day. Thanks. You
too. Bye bye. Bye.